The connection between production systems and
human cognition is both powerful and straightforward. In fact,
production systems, right from the beginning were proposed as models of
human cognition. We can look at it from several perspectives. First,
the working memory in production system has a counterpart in human cognition in
the form of short-term memory. Short-term memory and human cognition,
at least for the verbal part, has a capacity for approximately seven plus or
minus two elements. Working memory and production systems plays a similar role.
Second, people have connected studies which they have given the same problems,
both to humans and to cognitive architectures [INAUDIBLE]. These problems
typically are from closed worlds like arithmetic or algebra. At a consult,
there are strong similarities between the behavior of programs like SOAR and
the behavior of humans when they address problems in arithmetic and algebra.
This, however, does not mean that we already have a very good complete model of
human cognition. This is just the beginning. Humans engage in a very large
number of problems, not just arithmetic or algebra problems in closed worlds.
So there still remain a large number of questions open about how do you build
a cognitive architecture that can capture human cognition at large in the open?